partiamo da una storia
c'è un uomo che è in piedi davanti ad
una lapide era lapide della tomba di suo
padre
le persone che hanno seguito il funerale
se ne stanno andando dal cimitero e lui
saluta suo padre per l'ultima volta e
gli fa una domanda gli dice lo fa ad
alta voce gli dice sia io sia te eravamo
atei siamo atei non abbiamo mai
immaginato una vita dopo la morte Beh
ora tu lo sai cosa c'è dopo la morte se
hai voglia di raccontarmelo fammelo
sapere
Siamo in un cimitero di un paesino fuori
Torino quindi siamo qui in Piemonte il
giorno dopo lui torna a casa e riceve
una busta esattamente il giorno dopo da
un cugino che vive a Napoli la busta
contiene una coppia de Il Mattino di
Napoli il quotidiano della città
all'interno del quotidiano ci sono
cerchiate di rosso dal cugino due
notizie una è in realtà una storia è una
storia che appartiene al passato e della
storia della fondamento di un
sommergibile un sommergibile della
Reggia Marina Militare italiana e il
1944 sommergibile si chiama shangghy
viene affondato da una fregata inglese
che lo silura sommergibile viene colpito
e comincia ad affondare ci sono 50
Marinai a bordo quelli che riescono a
sopravvivere riescono a far emergere Il
Sommergibile si buttano in acqua nuotano
verso la fregata inglese che gli ha
appena bombardati Ma che litra in Salvo
sono 19 sono ragazzi hanno attorno ai 20
22 anni la fregata inglese chiaramente
li carica a bordo ma li fa prigionieri e
li porta verso il in Africa dove
rimarranno prigionieri per tre anni
questi 19 giovani sanno che a casa
arriverà la notizia della fondamento
della shangghi ma loro vogliono fare
sapere che sono sopravvissuti e quindi
trovano un modo per provare a comunicare
a casa o quantomeno per provare avere la
speranza di comunicare a casa trovo un
foglio di carta sono in una specie di
cabina che è diventata una cella sono in
19 appunto scrivono i loro 19 nomi su un
foglio di carta li arrotolano li mettono
in una bottiglia la chiudano aprono un
oblò E la buttano in mare
i loro 19 nomi sono stati scritti uno
dietro l'altro è in calce hanno scritto
in maiuscolo siamo vivi
l'altra notizia che è cerchiata su
quella copia del Mattino di Napoli è la
notizia di una ragazza che sta pulendo
una spiaggia per il WWF in Sicilia in
quei giorni siamo all'inizio degli anni
2000 2002-2003 mi pare di ricordare
questa ragazza pulendo la spiaggia ha
trovato una bottiglia una bottiglia
completamente incrostata dal tempo e dal
mare l'ha aperta e ci ha trovato un
foglio di carta con scritto 19 nomi e in
calce la scritta siamo vivi
quest'uomo mi racconta la sua storia al
programma che facevo all'epoca che si
chiamava voi siete qui lo incontro
personalmente e mi dice per me
quel ritrovamento quella storia era una
risposta alla domanda che avevo fatto a
mio padre sulla tomba il giorno prima
che se c'è qualcosa dopo la morte
fammelo sapere
io faccio questo mestiere da quasi 15
anni raccolgo il racconto le storie
delle persone lo faccio principalmente
alla radio lo faccio nei podcast lo
faccio negli eventi dal vivo quando ho
cominciato ho avuto la sensazione che
sarebbe stato molto difficile raccontare
le storie delle persone perché era molto
difficile che le persone sapessero che
cos'era una storia una storia è un
qualcosa che è una struttura narrativa
molto semplice è un inizio uno sviluppo
e una fine Spesso siamo abituati a
sentire raccontare delle cose ma non
siamo abituati a sentire raccontare
delle storie poi in realtà siamo tutti
bravi a raccontare storie soprattutto in
questo paese siamo abituati a raccontare
storie lo facciamo abitualmente lo
facciamo a tavola lo facciamo al lavoro
lo facciamo tra amici io in questi 15
anni circa di lavoro di raccolta delle
storie ne ho ricevute
20/22.000 ne ho raccontate 2005 in
programmi più o meno quotidiani che
raccontavano storie Pascal quando ero
Radio2 ora che sono tornato alla di 24
in un programma che si chiama storia di
rinascita o linea d'ombra di prendere i
punti di vista e le storie che ho
ricevuto sono soprattutto diverse tra di
loro ovviamente sono storie di vita Io
chiedo l'ascoltatore di mandarmi una
storia che dica qualcosa di loro e
quindi ho ricevuto storie molto
divertenti storie molto drammatiche ho
ricevuto storie come quelle che vi ho
appena raccontato ad esempio che è una
storia incredibile è un film questa e
poi ho trovato storie minute storie di
grandi passioni storia legate
all'infanzia l'infanzia è sempre quel
periodo meraviglioso che non tornerà mai
più per tutti noi e poi storie di cibo
storie di viaggio storie di avventura
storie di sport e tutte le storie che ho
ricevuto tutte le storie che raccontiamo
hanno sempre un unico obiettivo che è
rispondere a una domanda e con la
domanda è chi sono io Chi siamo noi
quando raccontiamo una storia quella
storia dice sempre qualcosa di noi
risponde a quella domanda lì cerca di
raccontare a qualcun altro Chi siamo noi
raccontiamo storie per dare ordine alle
cose per mettere in ordine il mondo e
raccontiamo storie per tenere in vita
dei pezzi del nostro passato Tra quanto
mostrare per tenere in vita le persone
che non ci sono più per farle tornare in
vita quelle persone capita delle volte
che anche proprio in un momento
difficile a un funerale di qualcuno si
racconta qualcosa di quella persona e se
vuoi qualcosa divertente ci si ride
anche se la situazione probabilmente non
dovrebbe immaginare che si Rida un
funerale di qualcuno ma perché
raccontando quella storia quella persona
è di nuovo lì è ancora lì con noi
per chi fa il lavoro che faccio io ci
sono tre elementi fondamentali da Tenere
presente ed è e sono sostanzialmente
Come si raccoglie una storia come si fa
raccontare una storia e come si racconta
una storia
Il primo elemento cioè come Come si
raccoglie una storia ha a che fare con
il contesto ha a che fare con il luogo e
con il modo che noi creiamo perché
qualcuno abbia voglia di raccontarci la
sua storia per cui Ad esempio se
decidiamo che una sorta di grande
scatola di legno con una tenda Viola
messa in un angolo di una chiesa è il
luogo in cui si vanno a raccontare i
propri peccati quello sarà sempre così
entriamo in un confessionale di una
chiesa da secoli ci inginocchiamo ci
sediamo e raccontiamo i nostri peccati a
un signore che sta dall'altra parte che
spesso non vediamo oppure decidiamo ad
esempio che c'è un luogo se siamo il
sindaco di un paese illuminato c'è un
luogo nel cuore dell'aretino in
provincia di Arezzo in Toscana che si
chiama Pieve Santo Stefano che da 70
anni è il luogo in cui si racconta si
raccolgono i diari degli italiani se
andate a Pieve Santo Stefano ci sono
8.500 diari di 8.500 italiani che in
questi 40 anni hanno deciso di
portarcelo di spedircelo di lasciarcelo
e anche voi se volete condividere un
vostro diario diario di un vostro
parente di un vostro amico un diario che
avete trovato in una in un cassetto
nella scrivania che avete ereditato o
che avete comprato da un antiquario quel
diario lo portate a Pieve Santo Stefano
e da 40 anni Quello è il luogo in cui si
consegnano i propri diari è qua a che
fare con il modo in cui Noi decidiamo
che creiamo un ambiente perché qualcuno
possa raccontarci quella storia
la seconda parte del mio lavoro che è
molto importante è come si fa raccontare
una storia a qualcuno
Ecco io credo che per far raccontare la
storia qualcuno se necessario mantenere
una certa distanza c'è una grande
narrazione e una grande narrativa sul
entrare in empatia con la persona con
cui stai parlando far sentire che anche
tu vivi le stesse emozioni le stesse
esperienze che ha vissuto quella persona
io penso esattamente il contrario Io
penso che si debba rispettare la
distanza che c'è tra noi e la persona
che abbiamo davanti questa cosa me l'ha
insegnata una delle persone che ho
intervistato più a lungo nella mia vita
per tre giorni di fila per un podcast
che si chiama oltre il confine che la
storia di Karin Franceschi che era in
Franceschi è un ragazzo che nel 2015 ha
deciso di partire da Senigallia la sua
città aveva 25 anni per andare a kobane
e combattere contro l'isis arruolarsi
nello ypg E difendere a tutti gli
effetti anche tutti voi anche parte del
mondo occidentale c'è stato per tre mesi
Poi c'è tornato di nuovo c'è andato tre
volte nell'arco di cinque anni Carime
con Dio l'ho incontrato avevo letto i
suoi libri avevo letto le cose su di lui
e ha qualche anno meno di me però era
convinto di poterci entrare in rapporti
in amicizia appena sono arrivato L'ho
invitato a cena fuori a Senigallia e lui
mi ha letteralmente respinto lui mi ha
proprio allontanato da sé mi ha detto
Facciamo che ci vediamo domani in hotel
ci facciamo la chiacchiera che dobbiamo
farci e io da carico proprio imparato
che mantenendo la giusta distanza dalla
persona che hai davanti e che deve
raccontarti la sua storia permette a
quella persona di raccontartela meglio
la sua storia senza fingere strane
empatia che non esistono senza avere la
situazione che tanto siamo uguali No
tanto Abbiamo entrambi le stesse
esperienze tante abbiamo vissuto
entrambe le stesse cose non è così non è
così nel mio caso ovviamente che non ero
mai stato combattere in Siria contro
l'isis ma non è così in molti altri casi
che mi sono capitati di incontrare in
molte altre storie che mi è capitato lì
di raccontare e poi c'è l'ultimo
elemento che è come la raccontiamo una
storia
Ecco anche in questo caso io negli anni
ho avuto la sensazione che per
raccontare davvero una storia io debba
fare un passo indietro e deve lasciare
la strada davanti a me Avete presente
quando vediamo o sentiamo leggiamo
qualcuno che racconta ed è così bravo ed
è così virtuoso che ogni tanto lo
guardiamo diciamo Senti fai così adesso
però spostati un secondo e lasciami
guardare la storia a me è capitato
quando ho raccontato la prima storia
della mia vita era il 2005 e avevo
deciso di raccontarla la storia di un
tizio che nella vita aveva fatto il
ciclista per tutta la vita Era molto
anziano quando l'ho incontrato avevo 82
anni è diventato famoso perché al Giro
d'Italia arrivava ultimo ed era stato
soprannominato la maglia nera si
chiamava Luigi malabrocca viveva
Garlasco in provincia di Pavia Io ho
scoperto la sua storia perché volevo
raccontare una storia faceva ancora
l'attore volevo fare l'attore diciamo
diversa da quello che ero abituato a
fare volevo stare su un palco e della
storia e quindi l'avevo intervistato per
quattro volte nell'arco di un anno lui
viveva Garlasco in questa Vecchia
Cascina e lui era un uomo che aveva
semplicemente capito che non era in
grado di correre alla stessa altezza di
quelli con cui correva e parliamo di
gente come
Fausto Coppi e Gino Bartali e quindi
Però se era accorto che alla fine della
seconda guerra mondiale nel 48 nel 49
con l'Italia sostanzialmente a terra
arrivare ultimo poteva essere un modo
per stare simpatico alla gente e la
prima volta che arriva ultimo a una
tappa del giro d'Italia ci arriva perché
fare una gomma non lo fa apposta la
giusta arriva in fondo e un tizio gli
regala una capretta e poi così di tappa
in tappa e poi damigiane di vino
bottiglie d'olio salumi prosciutti
formaggi addirittura soldi delle volte e
quindi Luigi malabrocca questa idea e
dice arrivo ultimo arrivo ultimo e
portava a casa più soldi che non se
fosse arrivato Quinto a un certo punto
la Gazzetta dello Sport Questa storia
non va tanto giù e quasi gli impediscono
di iscriversi a un giro d'Italia del 49
poi non succederà ce la farà e io l'ho
messo in testa l'idea di questa storia
quando l'avevo studiata Letta avevo
letto i giornali dell'epoca prima di
incontrare malabrocca che questa fosse
una grande storia romantica che era la
storia di un uomo che si prendeva sulle
spalle il peso degli ultimi per elevarli
al Rango dei primi ed ero arrivato lì
con questa dente in testa e anche in
quel caso è stato Luigi malabrocca a
farmi capire che non era così quando gli
ho chiesto la signora ma la brocca noi
adesso insomma conosciamo la maglia nera
sappiamo cosa vuol dire qualsiasi
classifica ormai ha una maglia nera cioè
l'ultimo in classifica Ma lei perché
l'ha fatto e lui mi ha risposto nel modo
più semplice e più nobile possibile
strofinando pollice e indice insieme
per questi Chi era la risposta più
nobile possibile perché lui doveva far
campare una famiglia aveva una moglie
aveva due figli arrivare primo era
impossibile e aveva trovato un modo per
arrivare in qualche modo in fondo e
portare a casa i soldi Ecco li ho
letteralmente fatto un passo indietro e
ho lasciato la storia davanti al mio ego
di narratore Io ho cercato di
raccontarla per quella che era purtroppo
Luigi ma la brocca è mancato pochi mesi
prima del debutto di quello spettacolo e
non l'ha mai visto però avevo fatto
leggere il copione E insomma mi sembrava
contento e quindi mi porto con me questo
ricordo Ecco a conclusione di questo
racconto cioè che in quest'ultima parte
della mia della mia carriera
professionale ho cominciato ad
affiancare il lavoro di raccontatore
pubblico
o di diciamo aiutante di un racconto in
pubblico alla radio nei podcast ha un
pezzo un pochettino più intimo ho capito
che spesso anche quando le persone
raccontano in pubblico in realtà
rispondono a quell'esigenza che vi
dicevo Cioè a cercare di rispondere alla
domanda chi sono io e quindi raccontare
una storia che sia identitaria quindi ho
cominciato a farlo anche in privato
anche da solo con piccoli gruppi di
persone in luoghi protetti Cioè non in
particolar modo che si trova
sull'Appennino Romagnolo dove mi piace
chiudermi con con poche persone e
lavorare su quella cosa lì cioè lavorare
sul racconto di sé lavorare sull'auto
narrazione per cercare di capire un
pochettino meglio chi siamo e con queste
persone che hanno voglia di fare questo
lavoro facciamo proprio un piccolo
percorso o un grande percorso Insomma
dipende dal punto di vista che ha a che
fare con il vivificare il proprio
passato per lavorare sul proprio futuro
perché non bisogna per forza essere
affondati su un sommergibile Durante
seconda guerra mondiale e aver chiuso un
messaggio nella bottiglia per poter per
poter dire a noi stessi e al resto del
mondo siamo vivi Grazie
[Applauso]